people know me as cherokee
but fred here brought the reggae vibe to
me and
then neil pogba said why don't you guys
get together into a band so cool we did
a band
and it's kind of like a reggae meets pop
meets soul music
so it's pretty cool it's new and it's
refreshing we have a lot of songs about
relationships and love and peace and
happiness and no war no violence
fred here does all the music and i do
all the lyrics and the melody the music
is really
just like a reggae foundation anything
as long as it has a chicka chicka
you know and and you could do whatever
you want like
it just kind of that one the regular
influence but
we're not jamaican or anything you know
because if we were jamaican we'd be
talking like this you know what i'm
saying but we're not we're not trying to
do that
right in jamaica
basically using like i take all our
songs
and i break them down into individual
stems like bass drums guitar
keyboards horns and i run it through
ableton live and i programmed this like
mixer interface so i could
do live dub mixes on the fly like kind
of like mad professor desks
but uh all digital we have a single
that's out right now and it's called is
it too late
and you can get that song at
esp3decor.bandcamp.com
you get a free download